I try to think like a man.
Uh,
I think that's one of the things that
allowed me to,
to get as far as I did get in my
profession.
But I never forgot that I was a woman.
So,
you know,
I would,
I would always ask a man like,
this is the disastrous situation we're
in.
I'm terrified.
Why aren't you scared?
And they would say,
God,
yes,
we're scared,
but you know,
we're men,
we're not going to show it.
And I thought,
wow,
I can pretend that I'm not scared and,
and maybe if I act courageous,
eventually I will be courageous and
it'll be a self fulfilling prophecy.
And that's pretty much what happened.
You can learn some of the skills that
men have and be more like them in a good
way and without losing the things that
make you inherently a strong woman.
And then I think you've got the best of
both worlds.
I think that women are wired to be good
leaders.
We just,
we just don't use all of our skills and
we don't pick up the things that the men
are doing really well and learn.
Some of those skills from them.
When the women who do that are very
strong women?
Well,
I mean if you look at the way that a man
is a man does not know how to multitask
because he's not going to be giving
birth to triplets were multitasking
would really be important.
So he compartmentalizes,
his brain is filled with little drawers
and he puts everything in these little
drawers and he pulled out a drawer and
when it's time to deal with whatever the
content is and when he's finished it,
he puts the door back and he doesn't get
distracted and so he's focused.
A woman's brain is kind of like my chair
in my bedroom and I was going to
college.
All my clothes and possessions were
always heaped on this chair and that's
kind of how a woman's brain and she has
everything is all mixed in,
all mixed up and it's a whole like a
big,
big glob of thoughts.
And in work it's probably better to be
focused to get a job done and
concentrated enough to do a good job
with one task and then go on to the
other.
Because if you have 14 balls in the air
and you drop 12 of them,
you know they're not going to remember,
oh,
you kept two balls in the air,
they're going to go get dropped 12 balls
and they're broken.
We're a guy's only juggling one ball.
So he can keep that ball going forever
and you know,
pitch it,
get it in the right hands,
solve the problem,
and then get the next ball.
And we,
we can learn to do that.
It's hard.
It took me many,
many years to learn to do that,
but we can learn that.